hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in his essay what libertarianism is john
hospers
tells us that libertarianism
as a moral theory and as a political
theory as a way of living one's life and
understanding ethics
focuses on a particular conception of
rights and the general idea
is that every single individual
has some rights we can call them natural
rights if you want that that's the
way that hospice talks about it you
could just think of them as rights that
do not devolve from a person's situation
or background or government
they are
they are theirs by virtue of being human
and every single individual has these
whether the rights are actually
respected or not doesn't mean that they
do or don't have the rights it would
just be that those rights are in many
cases
violated so each individual has certain
rights and these rights should not be
violated as he tells us a little bit
later he says when i claim a right i
carve out a niche as it were in my life
saying in effect
this activity i must be able to perform
without interference from others for you
and everyone else this is off limits and
so i put up a no trespassing sign which
marks off the area of my right
each individual's right is is no
trespassing sign in relation to me and
others so a right is a way of saying
this is mine and you can't take it away
or you can't transgress against it
without violating my moral status and
without doing a bad or wrong action he
goes on and he says that
every right entails a duty but the duty
is that of forbearance that is of
refraining from violating the other
person's right and he gives the example
of i have the right to life then you
can't kill me and indeed he's going to
say that there are three main
natural rights that libertarianism
focuses on and takes as paramount and
those are life liberty
and property now if that formulation
sounds uh somewhat familiar to you
because it's enshrined in the u.s
declaration of independence where
instead of property jefferson had
pursuit of happiness
you know man humankind is endowed with
certain inalienable rights life liberty
and pursuit of happiness that's because
an earlier formulation which jefferson
drew upon which is found in the works of
john locke actually does say life
liberty and property so that's where
that's coming from now what do these
fundamental rights involve so the right
to life includes not being killed
obviously because then you would no
longer have the life but it extends
further than that for the libertarians
it also includes not being harmed not
being injured in your body if i
happen to cut off your hand
that doesn't mean that i somehow
respected your
your right to life because now you're
maimed right um so or if i injure you in
other ways like i pollute your
environment and get you sick that would
be violating your right to life
it also has to do with not being
attacked by
other people so he has some examples of
this in terms of what laws ought to do
he says libertarians support legislation
as will protect human beings against the
use of force by others what are these
sort of laws laws against killing
attempted killing so attempting to kill
somebody is also wrong or bad
maiming cutting off somebody's you know
bodily parts beating
and all kinds of physical violence
so
libertarians probably wouldn't extend
that to say
hurting somebody's feelings right that's
that's not actually threatening their
life but there's a wide range of things
that are
the second right is liberty and another
word for liberty is freedom
the freedom to do something or not to do
something and hosper's goes a little bit
further into this for him he tells us
this means conducting one's own life as
one chooses he talks about having a set
of options before one being able to
select between these
right in accordance with the
alternatives open to that person and
here's the key thing without being
here's the key word coerced by others
so if i come in
to your shop and i'm you know being a
person who's a criminal trying to get
protection money out of you and i say
you know really nice shop you've got
here i'd hate for something to happen to
it i'm coercing you right if i'm
telling you that you must go to college
or you will not be able to have a job
i'm coercing you in some way right if i
am bringing pressure to bear on you and
there's lots of different ways that that
one can
bring coercion so we should be able to
do what we want without being coerced by
others
and he tells us again about looking at
laws what are some laws that pertain to
this well he says laws that protect
freedom of speech this is a big thing
for libertarians they are very much
connected with the discourse on on free
speech
freedom of assembly is also quite
important being able to get together
with other people
those things should not be impeded by
others unless they you know let's say
you're doing it on their property
and that's a good segue to talk about
the third main right which is the right
to property and this is a very important
one um hosper's clarifies for us that
the right to property
involves the you know the right to work
to sustain one's life and the lives of
whichever others one chooses to sustain
like one's family so it's not just about
oneself as an individual it can be about
others as well and then to retain the
fruits of one's labor so this is very
important
the libertarian idea is that people will
in fact
work so that they add value in some way
and generate something that's their
property a paradigm of this would be the
farmer who tills the ground making it
suitable for agriculture plants the
seeds
you know waters it throughout the season
weeds it
harvests it brings their stuff to market
that is their property that they're
bringing to market because they have
invested their own labor their own work
into it they've added value it's a
little bit more difficult say in a
corporate context where your value might
be you know doing something with excel
documents right you didn't create excel
and
you didn't create all the data that you
got but you did generate something which
is your work product right and you are
you're compensated for it
so property is incredibly important for
libertarians
he tells us
that it you know it includes not only
real estate anything you can call your
own your clothing your car your jewelry
your books and papers
your your your you know
knowledge could even be that
intellectual property right and he says
that we have the right to work for it to
obtain non-coercively money or services
which you can present in voluntary
exchange so what do we have to protect
when it comes to property says the right
to property includes
the
right to be defended against
confiscation somebody taking your
property
nationalization the government coming
along and saying your factory now
belongs to us
eminent domain again something where the
government comes in and says well we
need to put a road here so we're moving
your house
robbery there's a more individual thing
trespass trespass is when somebody goes
across your land or into your domicile
without having permission then there's
some other very interesting ones in here
fraud and misrepresentation somebody who
defrauds you
is in some respect attempting to take
away your property
patent and copyright
then he says libel and slander how are
libel and slander
going against your property because your
reputation
is part of what you own for a
libertarian so all of these things come
under that right to to property
now the the upshot of this is as he says
a little bit earlier in the essay each
human being this is the libertarian
doctrine
each human being has the right to live
his or her life as he or she chooses
compatibly
with the equal right of all other human
beings to live their lives as they
choose so
one can
enjoy these rights doing what one wants
to do provided one recognizes and
respects the rights of others
along these exact lines if i want
somebody else to recognize and respect
my right to my property i have to be
willing to do exactly the same for them
if i don't want them to try to attack me
then i have to be willing not to attack
them
otherwise i'm doing the wrong thing and
insofar as i transgress others rights by
the way that i act i am i am misbehaving
so that doesn't mean i can do anything i
like with my property you know for
example uh you know there's a little
silly trivial example used to be that we
had these lawn darts that were long
since outlawed and because they were
very dangerous
and we would they had these giant metal
tips on them
which made them really great for
throwing and you had little circles that
you would throw them into and they would
stick into the ground uh every once in a
while somebody would throw one up in the
air and then it would come down who
knows where and sometimes people would
get injured by them so if you're having
a pool party and i you know start
throwing lawn darts indiscriminately
into the air and they happen to land
near even just in your property i'm
placing you in in danger right even if
it doesn't hit you you've got to claim
against me because i violated your right
to life
by using my property in a way that i
wanted to
so there it's not that you can do
anything whatsoever with property
liberty or life it's that you have to
respect others rights as well
you